uh is this guy trolling me hey everyone
i'm abby sharpe welcome to abby's
kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by ritual and
we will be reviewing
health and wellness creator flav city
aka
bobby parish but first let me tell you
about my sponsor ritual
so first of all you guys know i'm not
pregnant anymore
but i am exclusively breastfeeding and
that
takes a lot out of me literally and
figuratively
so i actually still take my daily
prenatal vitamin from ritual every night
before bed
as part of my overall bedtime routine
now i know the supplement world is
really overwhelming but i like rituals
prenatal because
first of all it's third party tested and
it has 12 high quality nutrients like
methylated fourth generation
folate vegan b12 d3 and
omega-3 rituals also all about focusing
their multivitamins on the nutrients you
actually need and they're really
transparent about where they source
their nutrients from and
why as well as their environmental
impact
so for example they use 100 recycled
materials in their packaging
and their mailers are made from recycled
newsprint and plant fibers
their malty is also vegan gluten free
and allergen free
with no colorants added sugar additives
or enlisted ingredients
they also have a regular multivitamin
for men and women as well as their 50
plus option
but it's super convenient because they
just deliver it to your door as part of
the subscription
so even when i'm having super mom brain
i won't run out so if you want to try it
out you can use my promo code and check
out the link in the description
to get 10 off of your first three months
of ritual
you can also pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating i will be talking
about
macros and calories so of course feel
free to
skip that portion if it's not supportive
to your journey
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel and ring that little
bell so that you never miss out on an
episode
all right very quickly for those who
don't know bobby parrish is a 43 year
old chef
and cookbook author whose content is
heavily focused on
holistic nutrition and food advice so
naturally you guys requested this one a
lot
there's a lot of content on his channel
that i would love to discuss
honestly i could probably make a whole
sub channel just reviewing his approach
to wellness
but today we'll be looking at his most
recent what i in a day video at the time
of filming
and i'll be discussing some of the
general themes that i took away from
watching his videos let's take a look so
first she's griddling some of that keto
toast i love in some thrive market ghee
which is a great price for the
grass-fed organic ghee in the ceramic
pan we don't use any teflon in the house
okay so first of all i just want to
intercept here
i actually have a whole blog post on
non-stick options which i'm going to
link
below but to quickly summarize the
research
some nonstick cookware is traditionally
coated with a compound called
polytetrafluoroethylene or ptfe
which is more commonly known as teflon
so this is basically what makes nonstick
cookware
non-reactive and nonstick now pfoa
is another compound traditionally used
in the manufacturing process of teflon
and it is a known carcinogen linked to
kidney and testicular cancer we also
know that there is
some risk of something called teflon flu
which is when
inhalation of pyrolysis products causes
chills headaches and fever etc which
sounds really scary
yes but because the majority of the
pfoas gets
burnt off during the manufacturing
process teflon products are
not known to be a significant source of
pfoa exposure
or any of the adverse outcomes
associated with
pfoas also we don't often see adverse
effects like teflon flu
unless teflon is heated to 500 to
660 degrees fahrenheit which hopefully
most people aren't doing more
importantly
nonstick cookware has been pfoa free
since 2013. so as long as you've updated
your pans
since then and you're not overheating
them
there's little need for concern and if
you are still using old pans
you can reduce the risk of these side
effects by cooking on
low to medium heat instead of like a
really high heat avoid heating an
empty pan so making sure you add a thin
layer of oil to protect it
and of course using air ventilation
while you're cooking
my probiotic you're supposed to take
this on an empty stomach i've been
taking this for a couple months and
seed makes an amazing probiotic so bobby
uses
seed probiotic which is a combination of
lactobacillus and
bifidobacterium which he suggests he
takes on
an empty stomach now i actually have a
whole blog post on the best
time to take different types of
probiotics which again
i'm going to link to below but bobby
does actually have the right routine
here
so research suggests that lactobacillus
and bifidobacterium strains
do work best when taken 30 minutes
before eating and
ideally that meal has some fat even
having
a one percent fat content in the meal
seems to protect the bacteria
as the probiotic approaches the
intestines but actually all strains have
different preferred conditions
so a probiotic that is saccharomyces
boulardii dominant for example
doesn't seem to be affected by the
timing of the meal
it's organic jasmine loose leaf tea
just boiled water not boiling water and
you
pour it in and then set a timer for
three minutes to steep
loose leaf is always superior to the
stuff in the bags
just make sure when you get tea it's
organic the tea farming business
especially in asia can be really dirty
and they can use pesticides that we
don't allow here so organic is a must
i always put a scoop of collagen into my
tea in the morning you got to get
grass-fed this is one of my favorite
but this is also good for your hair your
skin your teeth your gut and your immune
system
okay lots to unpack here
first of all there seems to be a lot of
intense moralizing
around ingredients and ingredient
quality
i'm hearing a lot of statements like you
must choose your organic or
this ingredient is dirty this way or
this food is better etc
holy could he make something as simple
as cup of tea
more terrifying but anyways here's what
we know about
toxins in tea now it's not uncommon for
tea to be
contaminated with lead and aluminum
since there are heavy metals found in
soil and tea comes from plants
and plants are grown in soil period now
because of that
we know that the older the tea leaves
the greater the
heavy metal load now the good news is
that research suggests that
most contaminants found in tea infusions
are not detected
at all or are detected at a much
lower level than any of the regulatory
standards
but this of course does depend on
steeping so one study found that when
steeped for a
normal two to three minutes like what
bobby does all the teas tested well
below the established american toxic
levels for lead and aluminum and while
steeping for 15 minutes did increase the
levels
they were still largely below the levels
of concern
as for organics they may be better but
they also may be worse
in that study i cited organic oolong had
40 percent lower lead than standard
but organic green teas had more than 30
percent more than the standard
why we don't know so while bobby may
make this out to be
super scary it's really important to
consider the toxic
cumulative burden of your whole diet in
other words
focusing less on that cup of tea and
more on the greater
dietary pattern and that is why
again a varied diet is so key
as for the collagen i don't know people
are obsessed with collagen these days
likely because of the claims that it can
help to improve your hair
nail skin etc but is there anything
magical
about collagen for your beauty routine
no probably not so in short
collagen is a protein and like all
proteins
it must be broken down by enzymes called
proteases
in the small intestine in order to be
absorbed by the body now by the time the
protein is in the small intestine
ninety percent of it has been broken
down into
individual amino acids in order to be
absorbed
here's the thing your body only sees
these end
products it doesn't know that these
amino acids came from collagen
or chicken or fish or eggs or beans or
any other source of protein that you can
think of
and we can make collagen in-house from
the amino acids that we get from
any other source of protein even if you
did want to get your protein from
collagen
that's cool but it's not even the best
quality source
the collagen in most supplements we buy
is hydrolyzed collagen
meaning it has already been processed a
fair amount by
enzymes to be made into a perchable
product
but this also makes them even more
indistinguishable from
other protein sources and although there
are preliminary studies
showing modest skin improvements in
subjects who are supplementing with
collagen these studies are highly
uncontrolled meaning that it's hard to
definitively say that
these benefits are purely the result of
collagen supplementation
the reality is the subject's skin may
just be better
because of the increased intake in
protein period
so just to quickly summarize your hair
nails skin etc
all depend on getting enough protein but
the source
definitely does not have to be collagen
and it's completely false to suggest
that
collagen supplements will go straight to
your skin
or hair or wherever all right moving on
uh this is it pudding has a little bit
of maple syrup so technically it's not
keto but it's pretty low carb and
everything else is too and eggs
a lot of people think they're high in
cholesterol they're not it's actually
a good cholesterol it's good saturated
fat when you have that with low carb
stuff not like a white bread or
something
yeah like this really exactly then
you're made in the shade
excuse me you don't want the crusty part
on the end there
rose only likes the prime parts here
you know you're a parent when you put
the half chewed up piece of toast
in your mouth hey waste not want not but
anyways
lots to say about this breakfast here
let's first
talk about the meal itself now to recap
bobby and his sweet little daughter are
having a
two egg omelet cooked in ghee keto toast
with some almond cream cheese pecan
butter and sugar-free jam
and some carb chocolate chia pudding
on the side i love that we've got some
protein and healthy fats from the eggs
and tons more of those healthy fats from
the chia pudding
we've got keto toast and pecan butter
now
obviously this breakfast is on the lower
carb side
but as i always say you know if low carb
is what feels good to bobby
then it works for me having said that i
do just want to remind parents that
unless it's been specifically prescribed
and the clinical reasons for this are
honestly few
children should not i repeat
should not be put on a low carb
diet as for bobby's meal i mean it looks
great
i guess my suggestion would be if you're
gonna make something like an omelette
it's just a really easy way to sneak in
some morning veg
so he could throw in some spinach
bell pepper tomato whatever he's got on
hand
and as for his daughter i personally
avoid the keto bread
and give the kids some carbs so like
fruit bread oatmeal etc
a growing child needs a lot of energy
and carbs are a critical source but
other than that i think the issue for me
is not the meal itself
but the side of diet culture that comes
with it
let's break that down first of all bobby
mentions that eggs are full of
good cholesterol and saturated fat but
only when you eat them
in combination with low carb stuff not
white bread
that has one of the most bizarre
statements
i have ever heard but it sounds really
convincing when
bobby says it right so here's the thing
bobby is right and saying that eggs are
an awesome source of protein and fats
however there has been a lot of
controversy about eggs since
the fat they contain is largely
saturated
and they're also a source of dietary
cholesterol as i discussed in my video
on saturated fats right here we have
since seen some research suggesting that
dietary cholesterol from food has very
limited
impacts on blood cholesterol levels that
you would read in the lab
in other words it's not likely the
cholesterol
that's the big problem for heart health
furthermore
an updated 2020 meta-analysis stated
that
moderate consumption of eggs was not
associated with heart disease
and that it may actually in fact lower
heart disease risk
in certain populations like those of
asian descent
the current consensus is that most
healthy individuals not including those
with diabetes
heart disease or other chronic diseases
can consume about an
egg per day safely with many health
professionals suggesting
two to three being totally fine but of
course this is still a little bit
controversial
and as always i'm keeping my finger on
the pulse as new guidelines
and evidence emerges and you should
always run this by your
own health care provider if you're
unsure as for bobby's egg pairing
i'm sure it comes as no shock to anyone
for me to say that
nothing magical happens to the fat and
the cholesterol in
eggs when you pair them with regular old
white bread
versus his special keto bread what we do
know
is that a 2010 prospective study found
that
replacing saturated fat with high
glycemic index carbs
like those found in white bread was
associated with a
higher risk of heart disease while
replacing saturated fat with
lower glycemic index carbs reduced the
risk
so i guess maybe his thinking is that
by pairing the saturated fats with a
lower gi
carb maybe they kind of cancel each
other out
i don't know i can't be sure all i know
is that
we don't have to make nutrition so
complicated choose a bread
that is satisfying and delicious to you
enjoy your eggs and other sources of
saturated fat in moderation
and move on with your life all right
it's a vitamin thyme
vitamin c zinc and vitamin d3
those are a must because they're immune
system boosters uh you're taking what
iron supplement from thorn it's called
ferrous orb and
folate from thorn because i'm trying to
get pregnant just additional source of
iron ancestral supplements make some
grass-fed
organ meat okay this video is going to
drain me
so bobby claims that he takes a vitamin
c supplement zinc
and a d3 supplement every day for their
immune boosting effects
so much wrong with that statement first
of all
no nutrient can boost our immune system
nor we want it to because
an overactive immune system is arguably
more dangerous
than an under active one got it now
vitamin c is a potent antioxidant that
has been proven to play a beneficial
role
in both the innate and adaptive immune
system
by means of helping the body ward up
pathogens
and there is some evidence to support
its use for reducing the duration
and severity of the common cold but for
the general healthy population
supplementation does not help to prevent
you
from getting sick it's also a
water-soluble vitamin
so if you're already getting enough
through your diet which
i would say bobby probably is you
basically are just gonna pee out the
rest
as for zinc zinc deficiency is again
proven to cause severe impairment of the
immune system
which would definitely warrant
supplementation
however there's also research showing
that
excess levels of zinc in the body can
also impair immune function
just as much as zinc deficiency can and
then there's vitamin d
which is another nutrient that's
important for supporting the immune
system
and since most people are admittedly
deficient
i would say that this is one supplement
that i think most people
can benefit from to various degrees none
of these supplements are
bad for you or are likely to cause harm
and all of them have biological benefits
to supporting a healthy immune system
but they will not boost your immune
system
and they won't likely do much for you if
you're already getting enough of them
from food now bobby also mentions that
his wife takes iron and folate from the
brand
thorn which i checked out and it is a
third party tested brand
great however he also suggests that
people take this grass-fed
organ meat supplement that he likes for
extra iron
maybe not now although i do agree that
both iron and folate are
very important for a lot of women this
organ supplement in particular
is rich in pre-formed vitamin a aka
retinol which is known to cause birth
defects in
moms to be now i know that she said
she's not pregnant
but they did say that they're trying so
it's not something that i would
personally risk
now while the amount of retinol known to
cost issues is quite high
the supplement that bobby is suggesting
doesn't even
list the amounts of their vitamins and
nutrients on the bottle
so because there's no way of knowing how
much is in there
i would say stay far away now before we
get into lunch i'm going to
quickly touch on bobby's self-care
routine that he details in this video
i'm not going to watch this or go into a
ton of detail because
it's super lengthy and i'm also not a
dermatologist
i will just say that it's very clear to
me from the moralizing language this guy
uses
that he spends an inordinate amount of
time
thinking about everything that goes in
or on his body
non-toxic toothpaste it has no toxic
harsh chemicals that are very bad for
your gums
super super clean and for non-toxic body
care
non-toxic and harsh chemical free it
must be exhausting
i mean if we were to take a shot every
single time the guy says the words clean
toxic dirty etc we would be passed out
before the guy
starts prepping his lunch but anyways i
will just say that
not unlike the clean eating trend the
whole clean
beauty movement has created a lot of
mistrust
in the skin and beauty industry
perpetuating the false belief
that conventional or synthetic beauty
products
cause undue harm but it's worth me just
pointing out that
just because something is all natural
doesn't necessarily make it healthier or
more safe
and like food i believe that the dose
makes the poison when it comes to beauty
products too
literally anything can be a hazard for
you and your health
but it's how a substance is used that
ultimately
presents the risk anyways let's take a
look at what bobby's having for lunch
the bun is the cauliflower thins this is
outer aisle they're
keto they're low carb diabetic friendly
i smear around a touch
of avocado oil mayonnaise a touch of
harissa
nothing beats the price of the organic
sliced turkey
from costco then the costco prosciutto
de parma like a real
deal and then we serve it with the
fermented
cabbage here from costco too very
gut-friendly
okay so bobby says he has this turkey
sandwich almost every day
we've got avocado oil mayonnaise harissa
organic sliced turkey and prosciutto on
low carb cauliflower thins with a side
of fermented cabbage
that he tops with avocado oil and salad
dressing for some flavor
so a bit of a small lower calorie low
carb lunch
but we do have some fiber we've got some
protein fats
and a little probiotic action from the
sauerkraut which is great
but i do find it interesting that bobby
obsesses over his
clean life but he's fine with his costco
deli meat and charcuterie
both of which contain preservatives like
nitrates which have
long been shunned by the wellness
community for their carcinogenic
properties
i don't know i assume bobby doesn't know
that even nitrate-free
deli meats do contain nitrates
and that even natural nitrates like
celery salt
are not necessarily thought to be any
healthier than
the synthetic versions but yeah i'm
honestly just trolling the guy for his
hypocrisy
i don't honestly think there's anything
wrong with enjoying these foods in
moderation
i'm really just bringing this up to like
poke holes in his
holier that attitude around food but as
for the meal
again i would love to see some more
carbs in this meal
if not for him then at least for his
daughter
considering that those cauliflower thins
only have about five grams of carbs in
two
but anyways let's take a look at snack
we got the smoothie here
100 plant-based best-in-class
ingredients
uh it's the layered superfood
plant-based uh
protein powder it's paleo there's we
supplement that with a few extra
mushrooms you guys know i'm really big
on functional mushrooms second dose of
collagen for the day
this time i get flavored one with primal
kitchen laird makes
daily greens powder with prebiotics and
functional mushrooms
that's it cheers
okay so this is a post-workout smoothie
it's got frozen banana on butter
plant-based protein powder functional
mushrooms powder
a daily greens powder with probiotics
and some more
functional mushrooms collagen and almond
milk
that's a lot first of all i love that
this smoothie is
generally very well balanced and finally
we're seeing a little carb action here
with the banana to complement the
protein
in the protein powder and collagen and
the fat in the almond butter
great while we already went over the
whole deal on collagen
it is worth a reminder that it is
unnecessary when you're
also getting protein from protein powder
in the same drink just saying now we've
discussed mushroom based supplements
here before
but in short the research is largely
very preliminary
and very mixed when it comes to
supplementing with functional mushrooms
most positive studies state that
functional mushrooms
may potentially serve as an adjunct for
improving health
and wellness although we do still need
bigger
and much better research to confirm this
also i would say that in the context of
bobby's overall diet i mean the guy's
getting in lots of antioxidants in his
day
i would say that taking a greens powder
supplement
is unnecessary i'm mainly concerned
however
about him giving the smoothie to
his adorable daughter now ordinarily i
am a huge
proponent of family meals and that means
modeling what we eat
for our kids and serving everyone the
same meal
there are no adult meals and kids meals
in my house
but there are some foods that children
should not have including like half of
the ingredients
in that shake as we've discussed in
detail in the past
supplements like the various powders
that bobby throws into a shake
are highly unregulated and can be
subject to
contamination with heavy metals and
toxins
the functional mushroom powder
specifically would be a huge
red flag for me because even if this
product was third party tested
and safe for adults which by the way i
couldn't find evidence of online
we don't have research on the safety of
adaptogenic herbs and mushrooms in young
children
so repeat after me folks natural
does not mean benign not to mention
despite our society's obsession with
protein
toddlers protein needs are only about 13
grams per day
with too much protein potentially
putting strain on their little kidneys
bobby's smoothie here has over 30 grams
now obviously
i see she's just having a small portion
but still
outside of some very specific scenarios
protein supplements
are not recommended or needed
for kids all right let's move on to
dinner
this chicken if you haven't tried it yet
is a game changer
it's not just pasture raised it's
pastured heirloom variety
slow grown chicken i like that arugula
down there kale growing here it's
literally golden brown
crackling skin and delicious we got the
sides out here
the broth the packet of grains the salad
the beets rosie's already started here
poured a glass of keto wine no added
sugar got some pesto greek yogurt sauce
cheers is right does it okay that does
look amazing so for dinner we've got a
spatchcocked pasture-raised heirloom
slow grown
chicken that is a friggin mouthful which
bobby cooked with some ghee
and served with ready-made quinoa and
brown rice packets
a pesto greek yogurt sauce a green salad
made with vegetables from his vertical
garden beets and a glass of keto
wine that is the most bougie extra
wellness culture menu
i think i have ever described i mean he
may have beat out martha
and that is no easy feat and while
hopefully
the heirloom slow grown chicken tastes
better than conventional
everyone should know that that is
definitely not
a legitimate regulated term it also
doesn't necessarily make it any
healthier
and it's worth pointing out that for
those looking for a more
sustainable option a slow grown animal
does take more feed more water and more
land per pound of meat
to sustain their growth which probably
explains why these birds tend to be
about three times more expensive
than their conventionally grown
counterparts but if it tastes better and
bobby can afford the upsell and he isn't
concerned about the sustainability piece
then cool that is bobby's choice but
pretentious description aside
this is probably one of the most
balanced meals we've seen all day
as we finally have a really good healthy
dose of carbs
from the quinoa and brown rice i'm also
pleasantly surprised
by the convenience of his carb choice
it's just nice to see a little
relatability in his day
and nutrition wise i love that we got
protein from the chicken
and greek yogurt we got fats from the
greek yogurt as well
some of the pesto and the ghee and then
of course tons of beautiful vegetables
in his salad
balanced eating with a healthy side of
pretension
yes but with bobby i think i'll take it
however you guys know i have to say
something
about the keto wine so
i did a little quick research comparing
bobby's keto wine to an average glass of
dry
red wine and surprise surprise there's
hardly any difference
bobby's keto wine contains 0.26 grams of
carbs
116 calories per glass has 13.1 percent
alcohol content
and costs 21.95 per bottle
on the other hand an ordinary glass of
dry red wine has
three grams of carbs 120 calories per
glass
13 alcohol content and you can get
plenty of good bottles for under 15
bucks
so is it really worth the extra money
and effort to seek out this
special keto wine i would think that
even if you are fully keto
and bobby isn't you could find a way to
work in those extra 2.5 grams of carbs
if you really wanted to having said that
if bobby enjoys his keto wine and he's
willing to spend the extra money then
fine like who am i to judge drink what
you like
but i would say the world would open up
a whole lot more options and varietals
if he was able to let go of the stupid
bulls
and just buy a damn normal bottle of
wine at the store
anyways thank you for coming to my ted
talk let's take a look at dessert
i could either get some of my absolute
favorite
dairy-free best-in-class ice cream this
is coconut bliss
but tonight i'm feeling like a cereal
bowl
and i don't eat many cereals at all but
this coconut flake cereal from thrive is
amazing all it is is coconut
meat coconut water and then starch palm
starch not palm oil palm starch
the macros are crazy it's paleo keto
and it has a natural sweetness from the
coconut meat and because it has coconut
meat it has
mct in there so i add a little bit of
almond milk to that and that's my
dessert
it's literally just dried coconut with
some almond milk
and that's cool but i wouldn't call it
dessert now for someone who's not even
keto fully i don't see the harm in like
adding some
real whole grain cereal into the mix or
at least like topping it off with some
berries for some
natural sweetness i don't know that
would just be what i do
but it's also worth mentioning that
bobby seemed really excited
that the cereal had coconut so it would
have mcts or
medium chain triglycerides however
i think it's important to note that it's
very unlikely you would get a meaningful
amount of mcts
from a bowl of cereal seeing as coconut
is not a pure form of mcts
and only 50 of the saturated fat in
coconut oil
comes from mcts as it is but anyways
moving on let's take a look at the stats
for this day
so bobby's total nutrition for the day
clocks in at approximately 3 200
calories
with 26 of his intake coming from carbs
40 from fat and 34 from protein
and he's meeting most of his
micronutrient needs this would place him
in a moderate protein higher fat lower
carb way of eating
which definitely aligns with his trigger
happy use
of the word keto without actually being
fully keto now since he is getting an
adequate amount of fuel here
i'm really not concerned with this macro
split i mean
if this way of eating feels good to
bobby
totally works for me but he is a wee bit
low in
calcium vitamin e and most of the b
vitamins which
does make sense to me since most people
get
most of their b vitamins from whole
grains and he doesn't eat a whole lot of
that
but now let's talk about what i like
here
i think it's safe to say that bobby has
a very nutritious
diet there's no shortage of fiber and
antioxidants in his day
and while he's often low on carbs
i appreciate that he's got a nice
variety of proteins
and fats represented in his diet being a
chef and cookbook author
he's also really creative in the kitchen
i checked out his website as well
and i was really excited to see a real
range and recipes for different dietary
restrictions so
i think that if you were looking for
some new inspiration for some healthy
recipes
particularly low carb ones as that does
seem to be
his forte i think bobby's website would
be
a really great place to look now while i
would normally take some time to share
some gentle nutrition advice
i don't think that bobby needs any more
nutrition
in his day i mean if anything i think my
guidance tim would be to actually
loosen the reins a bit and to do it
before his daughter
is fully engrossed in this whole clean
eating
wellness culture that he's obviously
promoting at home
i would also say that with all of the
beautiful
healthy whole foods in his diet he could
also pull back
quite a lot on all of the supplements
that he has in almost every meal
so on that note let's talk about bobby's
relationship
with food because this my friends
is when things really head south holy sh
there is a lot of moralizing language
around food
going on here apparently food can't just
be delicious chicken and vegetables in
bobby's world
it has to be clean keto paleo organic
heirloom slow grown spatchcocked chicken
and vegetables spoken poetry to
from his vertical garden again like i
said
if this is all accessible to bobby and
his attention to his food
doesn't impose on or crowd into
other important aspects of his life then
great
no harm no foul but i think it's safe to
say that
this wellness culture fixation is just
not relatable sustainable or enjoyable
for most people
and there's an obvious level of cultural
elitism and exclusivity here
that needs to be called out i may
occasionally buy some foods organic for
personal reasons
or potentially mention that a product is
organic for informational purposes
but i would never suggest to my
followers that
they should exclusively eat organic when
i know that there are
economic barriers to eating in a way
that
the evidence doesn't even clearly
support
i also think we hear the word clean from
a lot of influencers
most of which i think just say the word
to denote a product with
less processing or fewer ingredients but
when bobby says it
or when he conversely calls foods out as
fake
there's a real sense of pseudoscience
fear-mongering going on
shame guilt and fear do not make people
healthy
in fact we know that common signs of
orthorexic tendencies
include compulsive checking of
ingredient lists
and nutrition labels an increase in
concern
about the health of ingredients and an
inability to eat
anything but a narrow group of foods
that are deemed
healthy or pure obviously i'm not able
to diagnose bobby
or anyone with an eating disorder over
the internet so i
absolutely am not doing that however a
lot of his behavior
does mimic that of some concerning
tendencies
in my books this is particularly
worrying to me as
bobby's daughter is watching and
listening to his
every word his daughter is at the age
where she is soaking up
everything like a sponge and we as
parents
we are their primary role model for
developing a healthy relationship with
food
as i've discussed in my video on raising
an intuitive eater right here
i am personally much more concerned with
the long game
of raising a competent eater than i am
about the
individual nutrients my kid gets at any
given meal
so i would way rather my sons be exposed
to a wide range of foods that are
described in
morally neutral terms than for them to
pick
up on an obvious obsession on
clean organic pure low sugar foods
and avoiding any and all processed and
convenience foods or snacks
honestly a child who grows up with a
heavily restricted diet
may eat really healthy when his or her
parents are in full control of his or
her meals
but children eventually grow up they go
to birthday parties they go to school
they gain access to the alleged fake
foods that have been demonized
all their lives and guess what they go
wild so remember foods may not be
created nutritionally equal
but we can make them morally equal by
neutralizing our language
and this is particularly important when
we have children around
this rhetoric is echoed throughout
bobby's instagram and youtube channels
while there is no doubt some useful
information around healthy eating
and budgeting advice and cooking hacks
a lot of it is also full of baseless
claims
and fear-mongering titles i mean things
like
top 10 fake foods how to reverse aging
resetting your gut you're eating banned
foods etc
like that is scary and i'm not
suggesting that our food system is
perfect i mean
it is far from it but we do have food
regulatory mechanisms
in place to help protect the public in
first world countries
like the united states and canada and
even when things do slip through the
cracks this again is one of the many
reasons
i advocate for a varied diet
the more variety we have in our diet the
less
chance we have to consume a dangerous
amount of anything
even potentially problematic remember
the dose makes the poison and foods that
do contain potentially problematic
ingredients
generally do so in amounts far lower
than what would actually cause harm
when eaten in normal amounts and bobby
does
seem to say that he eats pretty much the
exact same thing
monday through friday every week so
maybe just a reminder to him
to also switch it up so in conclusion
there are actually a number of things
about bobby's channel
that i really enjoy his excitement
around food
his amazing culinary chops and his
disregard for
calorie counting are all really positive
things in my books
however the food fear and overt fixation
on every and any little ingredient
is just so exhausting to watch
and while i know that bobby is just
doing what he feels is best for his
daughter
i also worry about the messages that she
may be picking up
through this as well so on that note
that is all that i have for today's
wedding today review thank you again to
ritual for sponsoring this video
if you liked it please be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who you'd like to see me review
next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you